hi guys
sue
my problem is um
that i just moved to a new neighborhood
and
um and by just i mean a year
and um
my neighbors are great but it's a small
neighborhood like five blocks by the
water
um i'm on the east coast but um
but it's it's small so you gotta be like
careful with situations
so this one neighbor she's across the
street and her voice is so awesome yeah
she has dogs i have dogs great
um but um
she lets them out
early like early like
six yeah and change 6 30 and i wake up
early my husband and i we wake up early
but like her dogs are out barking at
like 6 30 for like 20 minutes straight
and maybe i didn't want to wake up at 6
30. i usually don't want to wake up at 6
30. i'm looking for like seven plus
yeah
how do i talk to her
and not create a problem
because this woman's been living here
for 35 years she's an older lady she's
like probably almost 70. of course if we
do that how do you bring
uh that option also please don't say
spin moves involved in the answer
because i don't think that's going to
work with this i honestly i and thank
you i agree with her i'd agree with her
on that this isn't a spin move mentality
you do have to have the spin move
mentality because that's a
that's a defiant i'm me sort of
thing
that that we need to live
she needs okay you're pissing me off no
but we need to we need we need to a
sprinkler we need to
we need to we need to be clear this is
not a spin move situation she was clear
and she was right she shut it down
before you even [ __ ] went there you
[ __ ] she understands spin movementality
that's why you don't
i do i just don't like that it's your
advice for every single single thing
it's not this isn't have i said
85 no no so
i do wake up really early and even
i wake up early it
that would bother me even if i was a
wait already awake dude yeah right now
that is
it's a time of peace that early if
you're up it's got to be peaceful and
most people aren't up they're still
[ __ ] sleeping not mark walsh
he'd be like
i see those [ __ ] dogs
wow dude came early
premature ejaculation i think the the
way to approach it is just like
we all know this is not right i don't
know what's up with everybody else why
they don't bring it up maybe they're
afraid of you i don't know this is the
tone these are not your words but it's
like
wait maybe
45 minutes like just a little bit longer
if you need to let them out to pee maybe
you could put him back in just for a
little bit but like that's really early
and i'm sleeping and i think a lot of
people also are sleeping but like
come on what something's got to give
here this is just this is [ __ ] roo
you're you're being rude it is rude yeah
yeah okay i have advice
well that's what the show's for so go
ahead get a pet bear leave it outside
they they won't make any noise and then
the [ __ ] dogs there's no way that 70
yard line is gonna let dogs outside with
a bear next door outside did you think
about how often you'd have to feed the
bear what you would do with the bear
with the bears inside another problem
dangerous the berries calling with later
yeah i was trying to create more more
call-ins problems on top of problems
sometimes the only way to solve a
problem is to add a problem this is okay
that
is not only the worst advice
that we've given on this show
it is the worst advice i've ever heard
and also
and also it is the worst advice possible
to give to anyone about any single thing
no way get a bear dude get a [ __ ]
bear play
hardball dude hi i'm chris matthews
welcome to hardball be like that you
know what just say that to her call up
hello
hi i'm chris matthews and this is
hardball click oh by the way open your
window click and open the window and
there's a bear out there
and the [ __ ] dogs will never go
outside again dude sometimes the only
way to solve a problem is to add another
problem i'm krista lee and this message
was paid for by the chrysalia foundation
[Music]